so have you all noticed that everything
kind of sucks now and I don't mean like
the general state of the world I mean
like the stuff we buy is just like a
little bit worse than it was 10 years
ago and I really started thinking about
this because my co-worker Izzy wrote
about how she had to replace a bra so
I'm gonna do it any normal person would
do which is by the exact same thing from
the exact same place and then after a
few weeks it just kind of just kind of
fell apart so this kind of started me on
like this journey of like okay I'm
hearing anecdotally from like so many
people that I talk to like in my life
from coffee machines phones computers
sweaters they all tear or break or like
explode way sooner than they used to so
what's going on and is there a way to
climb out from under this pile of
consumer trash
foreign
so let's talk about this in the most
basic of terms starting with the design
process when a company wants to make a
thing let's say like a jacket there are
three main factors to consider
functionality does it work appearance
does it look good and manufacturability
is it easy and fairly inexpensive to
make a lot of this product
generally a good product will have a
good blend of these three things but in
recent years this process has been
thrown off balance let's look at clothes
for example in the past if you needed a
new jacket you used to go to a tailor
get measured choose a material and have
it made then for decades instead of
going to a tailor for a jacket we went
to department stores and bought things
that were mass produced by the 80s and
90s we had tons of options in stores to
choose from and now many of us just kind
of go online click add to cart and buy a
product without ever seeing it in person
but it's not just how we buy it's how
often we buy and for that we can kind of
blame this man
Ernest Elmo yeah incredible name in the
1930s during the Great Depression he
wrote this paper that was like okay like
the government should really like
support this idea of plan obsolescence
except he didn't call it planned
obsolescence he called it consumer
engineering remember that jacket you
bought well it's a new season and it's
out of style buttons are out zippers are
in so you buy something new but not
because there was anything physically
wrong with the original that's why it's
called consumer engineering right like
it was it's up here in the brain and
we've been living this way for decades
so now we all want the next best thing
all the time and that demand has spun
out of control
today we are surrounding the speed of
certain Trend cycles and the fact that
they're geared towards like these micro
communities like Stanley Cups when like
maybe a year ago it was like Hydro
flasks the result is that we buy a lot a
survey done in 2021 and found that
nearly 40 percent of UK consumers buy
clothing as often as once a month the UN
reports that between the year 2000 and
2014 the average person was buying 60
more clothing and each item was only
kept half as long so we want to buy a
lot of stuff fast and because we replace
our stuff so often we don't really want
to spend a lot of money on it which has
an effect too people aren't willing to
pay more for something they have
purchased a while ago so like if I paid
30 bucks for a bra 10 years ago it would
be really hard for me to buy it at fifty
dollars even though in the last 10 years
labor costs have risen so what we're
left with is an incredibly fast cycle of
demand for low-cost products and here's
what that looks like in order to speed
up manufacturing companies have to
either hire more people alter how the
product is made or both but they also
have to keep prices low enough for
consumers to keep buying so they may
start swapping materials like cotton or
silk for a cheaper synthetic material or
rely on a more basic stitching pattern
that maybe just doesn't hold as well
so if after 10 years you're still paying
the same price or close to the same
price for a product that looks the same
well something had to change
so you might say okay Kim fashion trends
are moving too fast and we buy too much
stuff I get it I get it but why does my
washing machine suck and that's a great
question let's talk about technology
when things like computers first became
part of our daily lives it made a lot of
sense to upgrade devices pretty often it
was actually very big differences in
what a device did that's two years old
versus one that was brand new in the
market there was just big leaps this is
gay Gordon Byrne she directs the
consumer advocacy group called The
repair Association you know if you had a
two-year-old thing you probably couldn't
do half the cool stuff that the other
guy could do so that kind of fueled the
replacement cycle because you really did
get something better in terms of
functionality for example when the
iPhone was first made it was a major
breakthrough subsequent phones up to a
point responded to Major technological
leaps like look at the difference
between the 3Gs and the four the iPhone
4 had a way better resolution and a
front-facing camera
for a while these major leaps between
models was the norm for technology but
we're not making those giant changes as
often anymore instead partly to make us
want to buy more things companies make
very minor adjustments year after year
so the drier you own may now play a fun
little song at the end of a cycle
instead of screaming and now as devices
Advanced and got increasingly
complicated there was another problem
for consumers all these things started
to come into the into the world they
didn't come in with repair tools they
came in to be thrown away basically when
this stuff breaks it's often
intentionally impossible to repair
because if you buy something that has a
computer chip in it or a circuit board
or whatever you probably can't make one
in your garage so you're very you're
very reliant on what the manufacturer
will agree to sell and very often they
don't agree to sell parts and tools and
Diagnostics or even give you a diagram
but sometimes it really just isn't
possible to fix because they cut Corners
just like in fashion replacing metal and
screws with plastic and glue and these
kind of issues apply across the board in
technology from your phone to toasters
to blenders to electric wheelchairs to
your car if you walk around your your
house or your apartment and you start
cataloging how many things you own that
have chips in them I think you'd be
really surprised how big
that lack of repair problem actually is
I want people to feel hopeful yes this
is something that's like out of our
control in some ways and not out of our
control in others I don't want you to
feel guilty for like partaking in in
this system when like so many people
even kind of brought up culturally to
think in this way or to buy in this way
compared to other things that suck in
the world we actually have a surprising
amount of control over this situation
with tech fighting for the Rachel repair
is actually extremely effective New York
State just passed away to repair bill in
2022 and it's not perfect but at least
it's something with fashion stay away
from micro Trends and fast fashion as
often as you can buy with intention and
learn to take care of the things you do
have think of like your objects as
having maintenance read those care
labels as consumers it's gonna take a
little bit for us to sift through all
the trash and retrain our brains a bit
but we can take small steps to take back
control of the process after all all of
this stuff is supposed to be made for us
so let's make it clear what we want
[Music]
we have a map on our repair.org website
where you can go find your state click
the picture and it'll bring up a um a
basically a letter writing widget you
type in your address and it says
tell your repair story and if you really
want to do something that's how it gets
done we've had over a hundred thousand
people do that over 30 000 of them in
New York so it does not surprise me that
New York was the first one to actually
pass law
because that's where there was a really
big ground swell of Interest